[Music]
victim's name is leo coppernick sir
it seems he was killed in the costume
store
[Music]
and then he was deposited here
staged so to speak
how much longer do you intend to hold it
all hostage
or is that the idea gather all the
suspects interrogate each of us in turn
until the mystery is solved marvin
cochraners overweighted playwright
celebrated play right
oh i'm so sorry sir i can't read my own
handwriting
[Music]
there was
an incident
i'll kill you
it's as good as a confession it's not
jump to conclusions constable
what do we have here
working late huh
he killed copronix to hush up the affair
case closed i'm doing it again aren't
you sir
jump into conclusions yeah
a little bit
you've never heard of richard
a real life detective
i understand that you came to blows
tonight in question
it was me inspector i arrest you for the
murder of leo cochran
we have a serial killer on the loose
please stand back he keeps the key
under the map
we are no longer merely suspects
we are also
potential victims
so what did he do that made you
suspicious it wasn't so much what he did
it was more the way he did it how'd he
do it sort of
suspiciously right
[Music]
foreign
[Music]